[Musique]
estelle bonjour alors doit-on s'attendre
à de nouvelles décisions ces prochains
jours
eh bien les biens c'est devenu un schéma
habituel un qui dit à conseil de défense
dit souvent nouvelle la décision
annoncée dans la foulée alors permis à
les questions brûlantes 1 se dirige-t-on
vers un troisième au confinement le
couvre-feu à 18h va-t-il être généralisé
sur tout le territoire ou alors le
gouvernement va-t-il opter pour un statu
quo alors on l'a tout de même avec déjà
quelques indications à qui donne la
tendance d'abord à ces mots de jean
castex les chiffres actuels de
l'épidémie en france nous laisse à
penser que le couvre-feu suffit c'est ce
que le premier ministre a affirmé dans
une visioconférence avec les chefs des
groupes parlementaires de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat et puis le porte
parole du gouvernement a tout de même
indiqué un qu'un troisième confinement
n'était pas prévu à ce stade en groupes
en fonction de l'évolution à des
indicateurs le gouvernement pourrait
éventuellement revoir sa copie alors au
vu des derniers chiffres sur l'épidémie
le statu quo est de moins en moins
probable reste donc la possibilité d'une
généralisation du couvre-feu à 18h
partout en france une mesure 1 peut-être
a perçu comme un peu plus acceptable
avec un troisième confinement par
exemple et puis sachez aussi que hier
soir le var et la drôme ont rejoint la
liste des départements son couvre-feu à
18 heures en ce qu'ils portent pour
l'instant leur nombre à 25 une situation
est elle en tout cas qui inquiète
évidemment le corps médical
oui dans une tribune a publié à lundi
soir dans le journal le monde une
association de médecins s'inquiètent de
la tournure que prend à nouveau à
l'épidémie il cite par exemple les
nouvelles versions du coc vide en
provenance du royaume uni et d'afrique
du sud et ses questions à qu'elle
soulève un quelle incidence sur
l'efficacité du vaccin et de nos
stratégies sur la sensibilité des tests
pcr aussi bref le constat est sans appel
pour eux on se rend la passion de ceux
connus 19 écrit-il et surtout pour eux
un confinement à stricte et précoce est
la meilleure arme pour lutter contre
l'épidémie je vous propose d'écouter cet
extrait il est à craindre que
l'aggravation de l'actuelle vague impose
mi janvier un nouveau confinement du
fait de nouveau de graves pressions sur
le système de santé
le confinement strict et précoce est la
meilleure arme contre la propagation
virale
même s'il est de plus en plus mal vécue
par la population reste à savoir vers
quelle mesure le gouvernement penchera
lors de ce conseil de défense et les
bonnes réponses sans doute en demain
soir puisqu'il nouvelle conférence de
presse gouvernementale est attendue
eh bien on suivra tout ça avec attention
merci estelle pour toutes ces précisions